[Music]  what may seem like a beautiful Oasis is  actually the top of an active volcano  [Music]  located in Java Indonesia is the koala  gen volcano at its top sits a crater  lake filled with hydraulic acid the  water is 90 degrees Fahrenheit and  appears a blueish green no species lives  in or around the water as the conditions  are too harsh for nature to survive at  night a rare phenomenon can be seen  unlike any other volcano in the world  koala Jen emits what appears to be  bright blue flames this blue glow is not  caused by lava but instead from a  combustion of sulfuric gases once the  gas is cool a bright yellow sulphur  forms which is mined and sold miners use  steel bars to break off portions of the  sulfur and carry up to 200 pounds back  down the volcano the emitted gas is a  toxic if inhaled making this strenuous  work incredibly dangerous  while this unique volcano may be home to  one of the world's most grueling jobs it  is also a sight worth seeing  you